In general, too much patient care
in the U.S. is provided this way.
In part, as we just discussed,
this is because of patient choice.
But, if all patients wanted a PCP, we
don't have enough of them to go around.
Only 12.3% of US patients practice
primary care versus
around 50% in France.
The same comparison holds true with
other advanced industrialized nations.
You can see here, the U.S.
lags substantially in the percentage
of primary care physicians.
The full reasons are beyond
the scope of this course.
But one of them is that specialist,
shown in green here,
makes significantly
more money than PCPs.
Yet, as also shown here in blue,
they leave medical school
with the same debt level.
So it shouldn't be a surprise,
as shown here, that over the years
the percentage of medical school
graduates selecting primary care,
the bottom blue line here,
has decreased, as the salary of a PCP,
as a percentage of what a specialist
makes, has also declined.